THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BURNER **** BATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE.
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN DAVID CHIU.
CHOI KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALLY.
DALY DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA.
FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE.
LIMON LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL [inaudible]
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS REYES THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH.
STONE.
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER.
WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VIITORS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN.
REVEREND PATTY OSHA.
EVAN NASH THAT.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION. TWO WEEKS AGO ON
APRIL FIFTEENTH.
THE WORLD WAS SHOCKED AND
SADDENED BY THE MASSIVE FIRE
THEY GET IN THE EIGHT HUNDRED
YEARS OLD.
NOTRE DOM CATHEDRAL IN PARIS.
I CAN EITHER THAT TOOK NEARLY
TWO HUNDRED YEARS TO BUILD WAS
ALMOST COMPLETELY DESTROYED IN A
MATTER OF HOURS.
IF THE DESTRUCTION OF NO TO DOM
WAS A CALCULATED INTENTIONAL ACT.
THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN OUTRAGE.
BUT WITHIN THE SADNESS OF ALL
WHO ADMIRED IN TREASURE THIS
ICONIC LANDMARK.
THERE WAS NO ANGER. FOR ALL
REPORTS SHARE THE SAME
CONCLUSION.
IT WAS AN ACCIDENT.
THE VIDEO PEOPLE SPONTANEOUSLY
SINKING HIM AS HE HELPLESSLY
WATCHED FLAMES ENGULF THE
BEAUTIFUL CATHEDRAL WAS MOVING.
THERE CONTINUES TO BE AN
OUTPOURING OF CARING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS HAVE ALREADY BEEN PLEDGE.
TO REBUILD THIS HISTORIC.
CATHEDRAL.
PRESIDENT EMMANUEL MACRON HAS
PROMISED AT THE CATHEDRAL WILL
BE REBUILT WITHIN THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS.
HUMAN BEINGS ARE CAPABLE OF SO
MUCH KINDNESS CARING IN
GENEROSITY.
WHEN I WAS THEM EYES TRULY OPEN?
OUR EMPATHY DEEPENS FOR WE SEE
THAT WE ARE ALL ONE IN THE
KARMIC FABRIC OF LIFE.
IF WE CAN LIVE FEELING DEEPLY
THEN HOW COULD WE NOT BUT BEGIN
TO LIVE.
WITH AN EVER DEEPENING CARING
AND KINDNESS.
NOW MOMMY NOTICES WHAT KINDNESS
AND GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND OSHITA WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE.
PLEASE JOIN ME.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
HERE YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY APRIL TENTH
TWENTY NINETEEN RECENTLY MET AT
SEVEN A CALDERON MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION THE
REFERENCE TO BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
ARE ABSENCES TODAY FOR ILLNESS
ARE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MULLIN AND
QUIRK
.
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE THE ASSEMBLY SECOND READING
FILE ITEMS ONE THROUGH NINETY
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ.
AS UNABLE
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN ELEVEN
TEN ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT TWELVE
EIGHTY SIX THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FIFTEEN SIXTY THREE SIXTEEN
NINETY SEVEN ELEVEN NINETY
SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO ONE
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN TO FIFTY THREE
TEN FORTY THREE FOURTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT FIVE TWENTY THREE SIXTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT SIXTEEN NINETY NINE
TO TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE
SEVENTEEN OH SEVEN S TOLL FIFTY TWO AT THE
MOMENT 1-723-174-0517 SIXTY
THREE EIGHTEEN AT 318-121-81620
540-914-03170 NINE POINT.
851-872-33290 FIVE FIVE SIXTEEN
BY 935-966-4046 536-727-0380.
806-809-8158 1-985-887-4940 --
394-109-1017 TEN THIRTY TO
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN ELEVEN FIFTY
TWO THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE THIRTEEN
NINETY SIX FORTINO 414-521-46714.
751-532-1550 415-911-66216
671-238-4620 466-736-8810
731-130-1260 413-405-4020
1-160-716-1817 THIRTY SEVEN
SEVENTEEN FORTY EIGHT SIX A TWO
WITH THE MEMONS FOURTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN WITH THE MEMONS SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE OF THE MOMENTS ONE
TWO TWO AND TEN SEVENTY NINE ALL
BILLS OF DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MISTERCALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR MISSIONS THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE WHEN EIGHTEEN A TO
ALLOW.
SOMEONE MEMBERS CALDERON AND
DAILY TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I ALSO REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT.
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MAIENSCHEIN FONG COME LIKE A
DOVE JONES SAWYER ABOUT OKAY AND
WEBER AND GRAYSON TO SPEAK ON
THE GERMAN MEMORY AS WELL AS
SOME REMEMBER BUFFY WICKS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SEVEN I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT -- UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY ONE AB THREE TWENTY
THREE DAILY TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE ITEM TWO
FIFTY ONE EIGHTY SIX INTO INTO
CARILLO FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THE CLERK WILL NOW.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER AB SEVENTY NINE
FLORA FROM THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO WITHDRAW AB
FOURTEEN HUNDRED CONVERT DOT
FROM THE PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE
IN ORDER TO BUILD A SECOND WE
FILED THE BILL.
IS NO LONGER FISCAL WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER
.
MISTER GALLAGHER WHAT FOR WEBER
ASSIST YOU RISE THIS CONSENT TO
RE REFER AB SIX SIX FIVE FROM
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE TO
THE COMMITTEE ON RULES.
MISTER GALLAGHER HAS MOVED.
TO MISTER CALDERON OF JACK'S HIS
SECOND.
MISTER GALLAGHER NEEDS A SECOND.
MR FLOOR SECOND BY MISTER FLORA.
THIS MOTION IS ONLY DEBATABLE
LOTS OF A PRIDE OF REFERRAL TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE MISTER
GALLAGHER.
DO YOU WISH.
TO THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I I
WISH I DIDN'T HAVE TO MAKE THIS
MOTION -- BUT MY BILL AB SIX SIX
FIVE ERIC'S LAW -- IS NOT BEING
HEARD BY THE BY THE COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN IN PUBLIC SAFETY AND SO
I'M ASKING THIS TO BE MOVED TO
RULES COMMITTEE.
ERIC'S LAWS NAMED AFTER ERIC
ANGER BRUNSON WHO WAS BRUTALLY
MURDERED.
IN COLUSA COUNTY MISTER
GALLAGHER CAN YOU PLEASE FIX THE
PROPRIETY OF WHY THIS BILL
SHOULD BE IN THE RULES COMMITTEE
AS OPPOSED TO PUBLIC SAFETY
THAT'S MY INTENT MADAM SPEAKER
IS IN ORDER TO UNDERSTAND THE
SUBSTANCE AND WHY IT SHOULD GO
TO RULES COMMITTEE -- THIS BILL
WOULD PREVENT SOCIOPATHIC
MURDERS LIKE THE ONE WHO
MURDERED ERIC -- FROM GETTING AN
AUTOMATIC PAROLE HEARING -- THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE IT NEEDS
TO BE HEARD.
ERIC'S KILLER -- LURE HIM DOWN
TO THE RIVER.
REALLY BEAT HIM WITH THE BAT
STABBED HIM WITH A KNIFE.
THIS IS A PERSON THAT SAID HE
WAS HIS FRIEND.
STATE YOUR POINT OF ORDER MISTER
CALDERON YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE MOTION IS TO
RE REFER THE BILL FROM PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE. TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE HOWEVER THE MEMBER IS
SPEAKING ON THE CONTENTS OF THE
BILL WE'RE NOT HERE TO DEBATE
THE BILL WE'RE HERE TO DEBATE
WHY THIS BILL SHOULD BE IN THE
RULES COMMITTEE.
POINT WELL TAKEN MISTER
GALLAGHER PLEASE FOCUS ON WHY
RULES IS THE PURPOSE SETTING FOR
YOUR BILL I AM GETTING TO MY
POINT -- AND IF I COULD JUST
FINISH THIS OUT -- NOW AFTER HE
WAS LOWER DOWN THERE AND AFTER
HE WAS MURDERED IN THAT WAY THIS
PERSON WENT OUT AND WENT ON
SEARCH PARTIES WITH THE FAMILY.
THIS PERSON ONE OUT AND SLEPT IN
ERIC'S BED.
THIS PERSON ACTED LIKE HE WAS
INTENT CONTINUED FRIEND -- SO A
SOCIOPATHIC PERSON AND A JUDGE.
HOW THE RECENT IS YOUR GALLAGHER
MY SYMPATHIES TO THE FAMILY AND
I UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF?
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO SAY BUT I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THIS?
RELATES TO ITS APPROPRIATE
NATURE BEING IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
ERIC'S KILLERS HAD TO HEARINGS
NOW ERIC'S LAW DESERVES A
HEARING.
IT DESERVES A HEARING.
AND THAT'S ALL I'M ASKING FOR
I'M ASKING MY COLLEAGUES.
ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THE
LEGISLATION THAT WE ALL PUSH
THAT WE AT LEAST GET THE CHANCE
TO HAVE A HEARING.
AND SO I'M ASKING YOU PLEASE
DON'T MAKE THIS A PARTISAN.
VOTE.
A SIMPLE PARTISAN PROCEDURAL
VOTE THIS IS ABOUT ENSURING THAT.
THAT ERIC'S Là GETS A HEARING
AS A DESERVE YES MISTER CALDERON
STATE POINT OF ORDER AGAIN
MATTER SPEAKERS BECAUSE OF THE
CONTENTS OF THE BILL STILL.
NOT UNDERSTANDING HOW THIS IS
RELEVANT TO WHY THIS BILL NEEDS
TO BE IN THE RULES COMMITTEE WE
ALL HAVE TO FOLLOW THE SAME SET
OF RULES EVERY SINGLE MEMBER IN
THIS BODY.
BECAUSE YOU FEEL A CERTAIN WAY
ABOUT YOUR BILL DOESN'T MAKE YOU
NO LONGER APPLICABLE TO HAVING
TO FOLLOW THE SAME RULES AS
EVERY OTHER PERSON.
POINT WELL TAKEN MISTER
GALLAGHER YOU CAN YOU PLEASE
FOCUS ON THE JURISDICTION OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE VERSUS
MOST MANY.
MASS FIGURE FIVE MORE SECONDS I
AM FOLLOWING THE RULES UNDER THE
RULES WE CAN ASK FOR A REFERRAL
I'M ASKING FOR YOUR HELP
COLLEAGUES IN MAKING SURE THIS
BILL GETS A HEARING THANK YOU.
YOU MISTER GALLAGHER.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS BILL THIS MOTION NEEDS
FORTY ONE VOTES MISTER GALLAGHER
IS ACT SEEING FOR A AYE VOTE
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR A
NO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE.
MISTER GALLAGHER IS ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE MISTER CALDERON IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED OF
A OUR MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
WORK WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE.
AYE AYES NINETEEN KNOWS FORTY
NINE THIS MEASURE FAILS THIS
MOTION FAILS
.
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE.
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY SIX S. C.
R. EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHT BY SENATOR HERTZBERG AND
OTHERS WILL DO TO THE STATE
CAPITOL BUILDING.
MR COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS RESOLUTION.
COLLEAGUES GOOD MORNING.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU
SENATE COST CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION NUMBER.
EIGHT MY CENTER HERTZBERG
ANOTHER'S.
RECOGNIZING THIS YEAR THIS
DECEMBER ACTUALLY AS HE HUNDRED
OKAY.
WE CAN'T EVER SIRI.
OF THE ORIGINAL CONVENE IN OF
THE STATE LEGISLATURE IN THESE
CHAMBERS.
THE BILL WAS NOT FINISHED UNTIL.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FOUR BUT THE
FIRST CONVENE THEIR BUSINESS.
IN THIS BUILDING.
WE FIRST CONVENE THE LEGISLATURE
IN THIS BUILDING IN DECEMBER OF
EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY YEARS AGO.
AND YES YOU ARE RATE
COMMEMORATES THAT DAY.
OUR STATE CAPITOL HAD BEEN
BOUNCING ALL OVER THE STATE
NUMEROUS LOCATIONS.
AND SO THAT FIRST CONVENING.
WAS THE FIRST TOP TEN FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENTER THIS
BUILDING.
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY TO FILE
INTO THE SPACE.
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE TO FILE IN
THE J. SAID SPACE.
AN ORGANIZED THE LEGISLATURE FOR
THE EIGHTEENTH.
SESSION.
REFLECTED UPON THAT DAY.
YOU KNOW THIS WAS OUR
PREDECESSORS.
COMPANY BECAUSE OF WHAT IT MEANS
WE PARTISAN INSTITUTION AND
RECOGNIZE IN THIS BUILDING.
THEY COULD HAVE LEFT THESE
CHAMBERS AND WALK TO THE SET OF
DOORS TO LOOK UP CAPITOL MALL
THOSE WERE IN THE BUILDING ON
THAT DAY.
THAT'S CENTER DOORS.
HAS THE BUNDLE OF STICKS FOR THE
CEILING.
IF THEY WALKED AROUND THE
BUILDING THEY WOULD HAVE SEEN
MANY SYMBOLS AND OUR
PREDECESSORS A HUNDRED FIFTY
YEARS AGO WOULD HAVE BEEN
THINKING ABOUT WHAT THIS.
MEANS.
HAD A CERTAIN THE SOUTHSIDE
LOOKING UP AT THE SENATE PORTICO.
THEY SEE THOSE TWO FIGURES
CLASPING HANDS IN FRONT OF US.
EAGLE AND A SHIELD WAS SIGNIFIES
OUR ENTRY INTO THE UNION.
IF THEY WALKED AROUND TO THE
NORTH SIDE OF THE BUILDING.
THEY WOULD HAVE SEEN THAT SAME
EAGLE THE SAME TWO FIGURES BUT
NOW YOU COULDN'T QUITE SEE THE
SHIELD.
AND LO AND BEHOLD WHEN YOU STAND
ON THE NORTH SIDE TO LOOK UP.
YOU CANNOT SEE THE SHIELD.
BECAUSE IN THE EIGHTEEN
SEVENTIES.
THE SEAL OF THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS SO LARGE.
SUPERIMPOSE OF THAT SHIELD THAT
OBLITERATES BASICALLY THE
FEDERAL UNION.
WHICH TELLS US EVEN IN THE
EIGHTEEN SEVENTIES CALIFORNIA
SOUGHT SELF.
AS A BIG PART OF THE FEDERAL
UNION.
AND LO AND BEHOLD THAT'S OUR
VIEW TODAY.
ALSO IF THAT STOOD OUT TO THE
NORTH AND LOOKED UP AT OUR
CAPITAL.
THEY WOULD HAVE OBSERVED THAT
THE THE DOME ITSELF.
SEEMS SHIFTED TO THE WEST.
SHIFTED TO THE WEST PORTICO.
AND THEY WERE REFLECTED THAT
WILL THIS SIGNIFIES THE FACT.
THAT CALIFORNIA.
REPRESENTS THE END OF WESTWARD
EXPANSION.
IN THE UNITED STATES.
SO THAT TOO IS A SYMBOL OF
CALIFORNIA IS SORT OF WHERE.
THE UNION ENDED ON OUR PACIFIC
SHORES.
AND THEN FINALLY STANDING THERE
ARE THAT WEST PARTICLE LOOKING
UP.
THEY WOULD HAVE SEEN A VERY
FAMILIAR HAS OR THE EIGHTEEN
SIXTIES EIGHTEEN SEVENTIES.
UP ON TOP THERE A GRIZZLY BEAR.
ATTACK IN A RIDER ON HORSEBACK.
AND HONESTLY COLLEAGUES I THINK
YOU LOOK AT THAT IT'S A VERY
VIOLENT SCENE.
WHY IS THERE A GRIZZLY BEAR
ATTACK IN A RIDER ON HORSEBACK?
ON OUR STATE CAPITOL.
THAT'S ON THE LEFT ON THE OTHER
SIDE IT'S A BUFFALO ATTACK IN IN
IN THE IT MADE HOLDING A BABY.
WHY AGAIN SUCH VIOLENT SCENES ON
TOP OF OUR WESTERN PORTICO?
AND THEY WERE STILL THERE NAY
WATER LOOKED AT THIS IS YES BUT
ATHENA STANDING THERE WITH HER
JOB HONOR SHIELD.
THERE'S A SUBDUED BEAR WRAPPED
AROUND HER FEET JUST POKING HIS
NOSE OVER THE OVER THE PORTICO
OVER THERE YOU SEE A GRIZZLY
BEAR.
IT'S A WHOLE STORY OF GOVERNANCE.
THAT IS THE FUNCTION OF
GOVERNMENT TO SUBDUE THE BEARS
THAT ARISES SOCIETY SUBDUE THE
HAZARDS ARE COME UPON US OUT OF
NO WHERE.
AND THAT IS HOW ARE EARLY
CALIFORNIAN COLLEAGUES A HUNDRED
FIFTY YEARS AGO.
ENTERING THIS BUILDING FOR THE
FIRST TIME WHAT OF UNDERSTAND
HOW THE BUILDING IS SAYING
SOMETHING ABOUT GOVERNANCE.
ABOUT CALIFORNIA.
ABOUT AS IMPORTANT THE NATIONAL
UNION.
ABOUT OUR WORK HERE ON THE FLOOR.
IN THAT FIRST SESSION AT NOON ON
DECEMBER SIX PERMISSION TO READ
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THEN LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR WILLIAM
HOLDEN.
CALLED THE SENATE TOGETHER.
AND ADDRESS THEM.
WE ARE ASSEMBLED FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN THIS CHAMBER. FOR WHICH
BEAUTY AND GRANDEUR IS SURPASSED
BY BUT FEW IF ANY OF OUR SISTER
STATES.
THIS HAPPY MAINLY IN OF CALLERS
BY THE PAINTER'S BRUSHES.
THIS INGENIOUS CARVING BY THE
SKILFUL WORKMAN WOULD.
THAT A HORN OF PLENTY THIS
GUARDIAN ANGEL OF THE LIBERTIES
OF THE PEOPLE.
AND THIS GRACIOUS SMILE OF THE
FATHER OUR COUNTRY SO THEY WERE
ALL THAT DATE UNDERNEATH.
THAT SAME GEORGE WASH AND
PORTRAIT WE SEE IN THIS OF
CHANGE THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY
THIRTY MORE SECONDS.
THIS RESOLUTION COMMANDS US TO
REFLECT UPON A HUNDRED FIFTY
YEARS OF THE PEOPLE'S BUSINESS.
IN THIS HOUSE. TO CELEBRATE THAT
ANNIVERSARY AND THE BUYER
ADOPTION OF THIS THE LEGISLATURE
RECONVENES ITSELF TO PUBLIC
SERVICE AND FAITHFULLY SERVED
THE GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I HEARD TONIGHT.
MR COOLEY WOULD YOU LIKE A
VIRTUAL OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
MR COOLEY IS ASKING THAT THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPENED FOR CO
AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRED ABOUT
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE THERE
SIXTY NINE CO AUTHORS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NO.
THIS RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR VERY SPECIAL
GUEST INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY IF YOU'LL INDULGE
ME I HAVE A COUPLE SPECIAL
GUESTS.
WITH ME JOIN ME AGAIN ON THE
FLOOR I HAVE MY WIFE A LEASE AS
WELL AS MY OLDER DAUGHTER.
CHARLIE -- BUT TODAY IS SPECIAL
BECAUSE THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I
HAVE BROUGHT MY YOUNGEST
DAUGHTER OUR NEWEST ADDITION TO
OUR FAMILY OUR TWO MONTH OLD.
PARTLY JAMES TO THE FLOOR FOR
THE FIRST TIME SHE'S TRYING TO
TALK IN THE MICROPHONE ALREADY --
BUT IF YOU COULD PLEASE JOIN ME
IN WELCOMING TO THE FLOOR TODAY
THANK YOU
.
A SPECIAL WELCOME TO THE ENTIRE
CALDERON FAMILY TO THE FLOOR.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
FIVE AC ARE SEVENTY TWO THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DALY AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO STAR
WARS DAY.
IS YOUR DAILY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. FORTY TWO YEARS AGO
STAR WARS TOOK US TO A GALAXY
FAR FAR AWAY AND CAPTURED OUR
IMAGINATIONS WITH THE CLASSIC
TALE OF GOOD VERSUS EVIL.
THE STAR WARS FRANCHISE HAS MADE
ENORMOUS CONTRIBUTIONS TO
CALIFORNIA'S MOTION PICTURE
INDUSTRY AND CONTINUES TO BE A
CULTURAL CENTER PIECE.
NOW THE OPENING OF STAR WARS
GALAXIES EDGE IS THE LARGEST
SINGLE SITE EXPANSION TO DATE.
AT THE DISNEYLAND PARK IN
ANAHEIM.
REPRESENTING IN OVER ONE BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT.
THIS INVESTMENT TRANSLATES INTO
THE CREATION OF OVER FOURTEEN
HUNDRED PERMANENT JOBS UPON
OPENING.
IN AT LEAST FOURTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS MORE IN TAX REVENUES TO
THE LOCAL ECONOMY EACH YEAR.
THE FORCE IS STRONG IN
CALIFORNIA AS WE RECOGNIZE MAY
FOURTH TWENTY NINETEEN AS STAR
WARS DAY IN CALIFORNIA.
MAY THE FOURTH BE WITH US ALL.
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR COURT FOR
CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER DALY'S SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS RESOLUTION -- OF MISTER.
MISTER MISTER CHOI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS AYE AYE YEAH RISE TO IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ACR SEVENTY
TWO SINCE.
THIS IN AND AND IS -- IN MY
DISTRICT GIVEN SOUL OF CORRECT --
BUNGAREE MAY NOT BE ABOUT THE
CITY OF ANAHEIM AND I NAM HEROES
SAY MY DISTRICT ARE SO WHILE IN
SPIRIT -- I..
M. D. CALL AUTHOR OF WITH SO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
TOM DALY AND THIS IS SO I
ECONOMIC ENGINE OF THE REGION
AND THEN ALSO CALIFORNIA.
MILLIONS OF OUR INTERNATIONAL
VISITORS COME BUT THIS OWN NEW
THEME PARK WOULD BRING IN EVEN
MORE VISITORS SAW TO THE REGION
AND THE BOOST ECONOMY.
AND THEY'LL PAY THE TAX UP TO
THE STATE OR REVENUE WILL.
OFTEN SO WELL THEREFORE I ASK
YOU ALL MEMBERS TO DOLE JOLENE
IN IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
AS A DISNEYLAND JUST OUR STATE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHOI MISTER
MATHIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS RESOLUTION.
MADAM SPEAKER THANK YOU QUESTION
TO THE AUTHOR.
YES.
BUDGET IS THIS THE BILL YOU'RE
LOOKING [inaudible]
FOR YES [inaudible]
YES.
MR LIVING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU.
MADAM SPEAKER AND THANK YOU TO
THE AUTHOR THE RESOLUTION VERY
EXCITED. FOR FOR FOR THIS -- AN
OCCASION IN FOR THE OPENING OF
GALAXIES EDGE IT IS WITH A LOT
OF PRIDE TO TALK ABOUT THE
CREATIVE MINDS THAT WENT INTO
THE BIRTH OF STAR WARS WE THINK
ABOUT DISNEYLAND OR WE THINK
ABOUT HOLLYWOOD AND WE'RE SO
FOCUSED ON SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THE VISUAL EFFECTS INDUSTRY THAT
WAS REALLY PIONEERED THAT REALLY
BLOCKBUSTERS BEGAN ON KERNER
BOULEVARD IN SAN RAFAEL
CALIFORNIA -- WHEN THEY FIRST
MADE STAR WARS AND THAT THE
CREATIVE MINDS BEHIND THAT ARE
ACROSS THE ENTIRETY?
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
STILL OF COURSE IN THE NORTH BAY
AND I AM OF COURSE EXCITED TO
SEE.
STAR WARS IN THE STORYTELLING
CONTINUE AS ARE SO MANY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS ARE STILL ENGAGED
IN THAT STORY TELLING THANK YOU
TO THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE IS QUIRK
SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
YES AND I AL ALSO I REPRESENT
WEST ANAHEIM WHERE MANY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS ARE ACTUALLY
EMPLOYEES OF DISNEY BUT AS YOU
CAN SEE WITH OUR GUESTS HERE ON
THE FLOOR DISNEY BRINGS OUT THE
BEST IN US THE CHILDLIKE
QUALITIES WE'RE WE RUSH TO SEE
THE CHARACTERS WERE WE GET.
OUR AUTOGRAPHS SIGNED AND DISNEY
IS THAT MAGICAL PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA THE HAPPIEST PLACE ON
EARTH THAT FAMILY SAY FOR MONTHS
TO SPEND THE DAY AT DISNEYLAND
IN ADDITION THEY EMPLOY.
MANY MANY THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE -- SO WITH
THAT I AM ONE OF THE BIGGEST
FANS IN AS NOTED BEFORE AND SOME
OF MY COMMENTS I'M ACTUALLY
NAMED AFTER THE ORIGINAL MALL
MOUSEKETEERS SHERRIN DARLENE.
WITH THAT I SUPPORT THE
RESOLUTION AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AS WELL.
THANK YOU WITH QUIRK SILVA.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS RESOLUTION MISTER
DALY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
Q..
DO I RESPECTFULLY.
REQUEST THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER DALY IS ASKING
THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE SEVENTY ONE CO AUTHORS ON
EASIER.
SEVENTY TWO WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NO.
THIS RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MR
DAILY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GUEST INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY IT'S MY PRIVILEGE TO
WELCOME.
JOSH TOMORROW WHO IS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE DISNEYLAND
RESORT.
BACK THERE AMONGST THE
STORMTROOPERS.
AND HIS HARD WORKING DISNEY TEAM
INCLUDING LISA PITNEY CARRYING A
CELLO AND LISA HAYNES.
AND A FEW DISNEY CAST MEMBERS
FROM OF FAR AWAY GALAXY IN MY
DISTRICT.
JOSH HAS OVER TWENTY YEARS WITH
DISNEY AND OVERSEAS A WORKFORCE
OF THIRTY THOUSAND CAST MEMBERS
IN ANAHEIM.
HELPING ENHANCE THE LOCAL
ECONOMY IN MY DISTRICT PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THE SPECIAL
GUESTS
.
MOVING BACK TO THE DAILY FILE
FILE ITEM ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
EIGHT AB ELEVEN TWENTY THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN TWENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES
AND ACTUALLY THE TOXICS
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
MISS REST MISS REST YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
PRESENT TO YOU TODAY AB.
ELEVEN TWENTY THREE A BILL WHICH
SIMPLY INSURES THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL RECEIVES PROPER NOTICE.
AND A COPY OF A PROP SIXTY FIVE
APPEAL.
PROP SIXTY FIVE THE SAFE
DRINKING WATER AND TOXIC
ENFORCEMENT ACT OF NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX REQUIRES OF THE
BUSINESS THAT EXPOSES CONSUMERS.
TO CHEMICALS LISTED AS
CARCINOGENS OR REPRODUCTIVE
TOXICANTS MUST FIRST PROVIDE
CLEAR AND REASONABLE WARNING.
AB ELEVEN TWENTY THREE OFFERS AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
ANY LITIGATION THAT COULD
ESTABLISH STATEWIDE PRESIDENT
REGARDING THE INTERPRETATION OR
APPLICATION OF PROP.
SIXTY FIVE AND ENSURING THAT
PROCEEDINGS OCCUR AS EFFICIENTLY
AS POSSIBLE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESERVE A ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
.
MISS REYES MOVES A CALL.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE OH TWO
AB FIFTEEN FORTY THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FORTY BY
SELLING NUMBER HOLDEN AND
ACTUALLY MUSIC THERAPY.
MR HOLDEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE 2%
ASSEMBLY BILL.
FIFTEEN FORTY AB FIFTY FORTY
DEFINES THE NECESSARY
REQUIREMENTS TO BE A BOARD
CERTIFIED MUSIC THERAPIST AND
PROHIBITS ANYONE WHO IS NOT
CERTIFIED FROM USING THE TITLE.
FROM NONVERBAL DEVELOPMENTALLY
DEVELOPE DELAYED CHILDREN TO
VETERANS LIVING WITH
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER.
MUSIC THERAPISTS SERVICE A WIDE
RANGE OF PATIENTS WITH NEEDS AS
UNIQUE AS THE PATIENT.
ENSURING THAT THE TITLE OF BOARD
CERTIFIED MUSIC THERAPIST IS
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE COMMUNITY
OF CARE PROVIDERS PATIENTS WILL
HAVE GREATER CONFIDENCE IN THEIR
CARE THEY RECEIVE.
I'VE WORKED WITH STAKEHOLDERS
AND DEVELOP AMENDMENTS TO
REFLECT THAT MUSIC THERAPISTS
CURRENTLY EMPLOYED BY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
DO NOT NEED TO OBTAIN
CERTIFICATION TO STAY EMPLOYED.
WITH THESE AMENDMENTS A. B.
FIFTEEN FORTY WILL STILL
PROHIBIT ANYONE INCLUDING STATE
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE NOT CERTIFIED
FROM USING THE TITLE OR BOARD
CERTIFIED MUSIC THERAPIST.
AB FIFTEEN FORTY HAS RECEIVED
SUPPORT FROM NUMEROUS
INDIVIDUALS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED OF
THE MEMBERS VOTED AS ART OF
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE.
I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
WE NEED TO FILE ITEM ONE OH
THREE AB SEVEN FORTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FORTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK STONE
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO CIVIL
ACTIONS.
MR STONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS WHEN VICTIMS
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN
ORGANIZATIONS BE THEY PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE.
SUBTLE WITH THAT ORGANIZATION
TOO OFTEN INCLUDED IN THAT
SETTLEMENT.
IS A CLAUSE THAT WERE THAT
PROHIBITS THAT EMPLOYEE THAT
VICTIM OF SEXUAL ASSAULT OF HER
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
FROM BEING RE EMPLOYED.
THIS IS A PRACTICE THAT HAS GONE
ON FOR TOO LONG AND IN FACT RE
VICTIMIZE IS THAT VICTIM OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT OR SEXUAL
IMPROPRIETY IN THAT ORGANIZATION.
THIS IS A BILL THAT WOULD MAKE.
THAT PROVISION NOT ENFORCEABLE
AND NOT LEGAL IT IS A PROVISION
THAT IS.
LONG BED AND NEEDED TO BE
EXCISED FROM THESE KINDS OF
AGREEMENTS BECAUSE THESE POOR
FOLKS WHO HAVE SUFFERED AND WHO
HAVE BORNE THE BRUNT.
OF AN OPPRESSIVE WORKPLACE ARE
NOW EXCLUDED FROM A CAREER FROM
A JOB FROM A FUTURE WORKPLACE I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT FAIRNESS MEASURE.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE MISTER
NAZARIAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER UP FIRST
AND FOREMOST I I RISE TO SUPPORT
AB SEVEN FORTY NINE BUT ONE ALSO
THINK.
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT MEASURE TO
THE FLOOR.
PROHIBITING A NO HIGHER
PROVISION IN AN AGREEMENT TO
SETTLE AN EMPLOYMENT DISPUTE IS
A COMMON SENSE MEASURE.
WHEN A VICTIM OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT HAS THE BRAVERY TO
COME FORWARD AND CONFRONT THEIR
ABUSER THEY SHOULD NOT BE RE
VICTIMIZED WITH A NO HIGHER
PROVISION IN THERE SETTLEMENT --
COLLEAGUES I HAD A CONSTITUENT
WHO APPROACHED ME ABOUT FIVE
YEARS AGO FOUR YEARS AGO.
AND AND THROUGH LETTER WRITING
AND STARTED TELLING ME ABOUT THE
SITUATION THAT HAPPENED. TO HER
DAUGHTER.
AT A UNIVERSITY AT A PUBLIC
STATE UNIVERSITY WHERE.
WHILE SHE HAD BEEN A VICTIM HER
DAUGHTER HAD BEEN A VICTIM.
OF A SEXUAL HARASSMENT CASE.
YOUR ATTENTION MISTER NAZARIAN
PLEASE.
WELL SHE HAD BEEN A VICTIM OF A
SEXUAL HARASSMENT CASE -- THE
SCHOOL HAD REALLY NOT DONE TAKEN
THE APPROPRIATE STEPS TO ADDRESS
THE IN THE MATTER.
IN FACT WHEN EVERYTHING WAS SAID
AND DONE.
THE ISSUE WAS RESOLVED WITH THAT.
WITH MY CONSTITUENT.
NOT BEING ABLE TO GO BACK TO THE
SCHOOL AND NEVER BEING ABLE TO
GRADUATE WITH A DEGREE NOR EVER
BEING ABLE TO WORK.
AT ANY OF THE INSTITUTIONS.
AND THE SCHOOL DID THIS FULLY
WELL KNOWING THAT THE DEGREE
THAT THE STUDENT WAS GETTING
FROM THE UNIVERSITY.
WAS GOING TO ENABLE HER TO WORK
AT THAT UNIVERSITY.
IT WAS EXTREMELY A PUNITIVE
MEASURE AND THIS IS BEEN GOING
ON FOR SOME TIME AND THAT'S WHY
VERY MUCH VALUE THE FACT THAT
THE OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM -- UP
MONTEREY HAS -- BROUGHT THIS
FORWARD AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK TO BE A CO AUTHOR AS WELL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN.
IN AND WILL GO UP AND DOWN.
MR STAND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
ON THIS MATTER.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS ART OF A
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
ARM MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
MR STONE IS THE CALL. NINETY
FILE ITEM ONE OH FIVE AB TWO
SIXTY TWO THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SIXTY TWO BY
SELLING OVER GLORIA AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
MR GLORY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SAN YOU
EXPERIENCE ONE OF THE DEADLIEST
OUTBREAK OF HEPATITIS A SINCE
THE VACCINE FOR THE DISEASE WAS
BECAME AVAILABLE IN.
NINETEEN NINETY SIX THE OTHERS
OTHERWISE ENTIRELY PREVENTABLE
DISEASE BEGAN TO SPREAD IN IT IS
IT DID IT DID SO I UNBELIEVABLE
RATE.
REACHING ORANGE LOS ANGELES AND
EVEN AS FAR AS SANTA CRUZ COUNTY.
STATE INTERVENTION BECAME SO
DESPERATELY NEEDED AS A RESULT
OF THIS OUTBREAK ORIGINATING IN
SAN DIEGO THE FORMER GOVERNOR
BROWN ISSUED AN EMERGENCY
PROCLAMATION ON OCTOBER
THIRTEENTH. TWENTY SEVENTEEN
FOLLOWING THE CONTAINMENT OF THE
OUTBREAK I REQUESTED OUR STATE
AUDITOR TO REVIEW THE MANAGEMENT
OF THE HEPATITIS A OUTBREAK.
SHE PROVIDED A NUMBER OF
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ALL
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES INVOLVED
THIS BILL IS A DIRECT PRODUCT OF
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS.
AB TWO SIXTY TWO MAKES IT CLEAR
THAT THE RESPONSIBILITIES LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
AGAINST FUTURE COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE OUTBREAKS SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILL CLARIFIES A LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS AUTHORITY TO
ISSUE HEALTH ORDERS. TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IN RESPONSE TO
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE OUTBREAK
AND REQUIRES A LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICER TO MAKE RELEVANT
INFORMATION RELATED TO THE
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE AVAILABLE
TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WITH IN
THAT COUNTY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE MADAM SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THEIR ALL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS ART OF A
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
HOW LONG MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE?
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE TWELVE
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FORTY
THREE BY SOME REMEMBER BLOOM AND
ACTUALLY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
MR BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
HONEST THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE
EXPANDS THE PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTION FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS TO INCLUDE.
MALLORY SPECIAL TAXES THE
BELARUS ACT WAS PASSED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO AND ALLOWS
COUNTY CITIES SPECIAL DISTRICTS
OR JOINT POWER AUTHORITY. TO
ESTABLISH A COMMUNITY FACILITIES
DISTRICT WITH VOTER APPROVAL.
RESIDENTS RESIDING IN A
COMMUNITY FACILITIES DISTRICT
ARE ASSESSED A SPECIAL TAX ON
TOP OF THEIR PROPERTY TAX TO
HELP FUND LOCAL SERVICES
INCLUDING SCHOOLS AND CITY
MAINTENANCE SERVICES AND
CURRENTLY.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS ARE
EXEMPT FROM PAYING PROPERTY
TAXES AND THAT HELPS THEM REDUCE
THE ANNUAL OPERATING COSTS.
OF LOW INCOME HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS HOWEVER THE
EXEMPTION CURRENTLY DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE MALLORY SPECIAL TAX
WHICH CAN BE AS MUCH AS A
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER UNIT PER
YEAR.
IF IT WAS SAY A FIFTY UNIT
BUILDING THAT WOULD BE FIFTY
THOUSAND A YEAR THAT'S REAL
MONEY FOR THESE PROJECTS IN THIS
BILL.
ADDRESSES THAT OMISSION THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED MANY
CRUCIAL POLICIES TO HELP FINANCE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND REMOVE
BARRIERS IN CONCERT AND
CONSTRAINTS DEVELOPMENT.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE WILL
INCREMENTALLY HELP CONTINUE OUR
EFFORTS TO INCREASE THE SUPPLY
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND REDUCE
THE FINANCIAL BARRIERS TO
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
LONG MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A THE
CLERK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE AYE SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES
.
WE'RE PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL
ON AB ELEVEN TWENTY THREE RIGHT
YES.
CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THAT.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES I SIX FIFTY SIX
KNOWS NINETEEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE FOURTEEN
AB SEVEN FORTY THREE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FORTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
PEOPLE HEALTH.
MR GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER A. B. SEVEN FORTY
THREE IS A BILL THAT WOULD
REQUIRE SCHOOL DISTRICTS. TO
ACCEPT WRITTEN STATEMENTS FOR
SELF ADMINISTERING ASTHMA
INHALERS FROM A LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL WHO IS CONTRACTED
WITH A BI NATIONAL HEALTH PLAN.
THAT IS OVERSEEN BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND LICENSE BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
CARE AND COMPLIANCE WITH ALL OF
THE STANDARDS OF THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT.
YOU SEE IN OUR DISTRICT.
MANY PEOPLE ACROSS THE BORDER TO
RECEIVE HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR
MANY REASONS COST CULTURAL
COMPETENCY AND GREATER
ACCESSIBILITY.
WE HAVE CHILDREN AND YOU'VE
HEARD ME MENTION THIS BEFORE IN
OUR DISTRICT AND OVER 50% OF
THEM SUFFER FROM RESPIRATORY
DISEASE PROBLEMS.
WE'VE BEEN INTRODUCED TO A
PROBLEM.
THAT SAYS THAT THOSE CHILDREN
WHO HAVE THESE.
BI NATIONAL HEALTH PLANS CANNOT
USE THEIR MEDICATION AT SCHOOL.
AND SO THIS.
LAW WOULD CHANGE THAT ENSURE
THAT.
EXPANDING HEALTH CARE TO
EVERYONE IN THIS CASE YOUNG
CHILDREN IN OUR SCHOOLS.
IS THE MAIN FOCUS SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MR GARCIA SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THAT I SIXTY SIX NEWS HERE
THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTEEN
AB TWO SEVENTY TWO THE CLERK
WILL READ.
A SOME LEGAL TO SEVENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SU CHI AND
ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE'S.
THIS MESSAGE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH COLLEAGUES I'M ASKING
ALL OF YOU.
TO PUT DOWN YOUR SMART.
AND TO PAY ATTENTION IN CLASS.
THIS IS A BILL THAT'S THE AS WE
ALL KNOW WE KNOW HOW IT
DETECTIVE SMART PHONES CAN BE.
AND THERE IS GROWING EVIDENCE
THAT THIS IS POSING A PROBLEM IN
OUR CLASSROOMS.
THERE'S GROWING EVIDENCE SHOWING
THAT ACCESO SMART SMART PHONE
USE AT SCHOOL IS INTERFERING
WITH OUR STUDENTS EDUCATION.
ENCOURAGING CYBER BULLYING AND
HAVING ADVERSE EFFECTS ON
TEENAGE MENTAL HEALTH.
LAST YEAR FRANCE BANS
SMARTPHONES IN ELEMENTARY AND
MIDDLE SCHOOLS.
THERE WAS A STUDY FROM THE
LONDON SCHOOL OF ECONOMICS THAT
SHOWS THAT THE SMART PHONES AND
CLASSROOMS IS HAVING A AN IMPACT
ON THE CHIEF AND GAP ESPECIALLY
ON THE THE LOWEST PERFORMING
STUDENTS.
AND THAT THERE IS A BOOK A BEST
SELLING BOOK ALL CALLED AYE CHEN
THAT AS PART OF A GROWING BODY
OF EVIDENCE SHOWING THE IMPACTS
OF SMARTPHONES EXCESSIVE YOU
FEELS OF A SMART PHONES.
ON TEENAGE ANXIETY DEPRESSION
AND SUICIDE [inaudible]
THIS BILL.
WILL PERMIT AND HOPEFULLY
ENCOURAGE BUT NOT REQUIRE.
AS SCHOOL DISTRICT TO ADOPT
THEIR OWN POLICY TO STRIKE A
BALANCE BETWEEN ALLOWING
APPROPRIATE STUDENTUSE OF
SMARTPHONES WHILE MAKING SURE
THAT SMARTPHONES ARE NOT
INTERFERING WITH THE STUDENT'S.
EDUCATIONAL SOCIAL OR EMOTIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
THIS IS NOT A BILL IF IF YOU
WANT TO ALLOW PARENTS TO
CONTINUE TO STAY IN TOUCH WITH
THEIR KIDS.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND GOOD CAN DO
THAT IF YOU WANT TO ALLOW
STUDENTS TO CONTINUE TO USE OF
SMARTPHONES AS AN ACADEMIC
RESOURCE.
STUDENT SCHOOL DISTRICT AND DO
THAT.
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN ALLOW
STUDENTS TO CONTINUE TO USE
THEIR SMARTPHONES FOR MEDICAL OR
OTHER CAMPUS EMERGENCIES.
THE KEY HERE IS STRIKING A
BALANCE THIS BILL IS RECEIVED A
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WITH NO
OPPOSITION I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MAYOR SU CHI'S
SEEING IN HE THIS WORKS -- YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER --
YES MEMBERS I ALSO INCLUDE --
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN TWO AS A CLASSROOM TEACHER
SEEN THE CHANGES OVER THE LAST
DECADES WITH STUDENTS NOW HAVING
MORE AND MORE TECHNOLOGY AT
THEIR FINGERTIPS THERE CERTAINLY
HAVE BEEN SOME.
POSITIVE RESULTS FROM THAT BUT
MORE AND MORE WE HAVE SEEN
STUDENTS.
ACTUALLY SHOWING SIGNS OF
ISOLATION WHERE WE SEE STUDENTS.
AT A BREAK PERIOD NOT
INTERACTING WITH EACH OTHER BUT
INTERACTING WITH THEIR PHONES
INSTEAD IN ADDITION TO THAT WE
SEE THAT MORE AND MORE FAMILIES
ARE DOING THAT IF YOU LOOK AT
THE DINNER TABLE OR AT A
RESTAURANT.
AND WITH THIS WE KNOW THAT THERE
IS SOME RESPONSE UP IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA THEY HAVE THE WALDEN
SCHOOLS WHO HAVE ACTUALLY MADE
THE DECISION TO HAVE NO
TECHNOLOGY.
BUT IN ORANGE COUNTY WE HAVE
TRIED KERR SPITTLE AND SHOCK
HOSPITAL JUST OPENED UP BUT
ADOLESCENT WARD AND I ASKED HIM
WHY AND THEY SAID THAT THEY HAVE
SEEN MORE AND MORE SIGNS OF
YOUNG ADULTS ADOLESCENTS.
WITH SUICIDE THOUGHTS WITH
DEPRESSION AND EVEN YOUNG GIRLS
AT THE YOUNGEST AGES OF TEN
ELEVEN AND TWELVE HAVING ISSUES
WITH BULIMIA AND ANOREXIA.
SOME OF THEIR THEORY THERE IS OR
SEEN SO MANY IMAGES FROM PHONES
IN A SOCIAL MEDIA SITES THAT
THEY JUST DON'T FEEL THAT THEY
CAN NEVER MEASURE UP SO I
SUPPORT THIS AND HOPE YOU WILL
SUPPORT AB.
TWO SEVEN TWO THANK YOU MISS
QUIRK SILVA MISS MELENDEZ YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU -- I HAVE A QUESTION
OF THE AUTHOR BUT I DON'T SEE
HIM -- THERE IS OUT OKAY I'M
DISEASE WITHOUT OBJECTION THANK
YOU DOES THIS BILL ALSO OUR ICE
THE SUGGESTION FOR THE POLICY
DOES THIS APPLY TO TEACHERS AS
WELL.
ARE JUST STUDENTS BECAUSE IT
WELL LET ALLEGE INTO THE
QUESTION FIRST.
IT DOES NOT IT DOES NOT OKAY AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I WILL
BE VOTING FOR TODAY I JUST.
HOPE THAT -- WHEN IMPLEMENTING
THIS POLICY THAT THE SUPPLIES
THAT TEACHERS AS WELL BECAUSE I
AM KIDS IN MIDDLE SCHOOL TWO OF
THEM?
AND 95% AS A PRINCIPAL TOLD ME --
JUST THIS WEEK 95% OF THOSE KIDS
HAVE A SMARTPHONE WHICH BLOWS MY
MIND MEAN THESE ARE SIX GRADERS.
AND AND THEY ALL HAVE MEN SCHOOL.
IN IT'S NOT JUST THE KIDS WHO
ARE USING THEM IT'S THE TEACHERS
WHO ARE USING THEM IN CLASS AS
WELL WHICH SENDS KIND OF THE
WRONG MESSAGE I THINK WE'RE
GONNA ASK OUR STUDENTS TO STAY
UP THEIR PHONES.
THE TEACHER SHOULD AS WELL SO
THAT WOULD JUST BE MY SUGGESTION
JUST LET'S MAKE SURE WE'RE
ENCOURAGING TEACHERS TO DO TODAY
MY FULLY SUPPORT THE IDEA.
THANK YOU MISS MELENDEZ MISTER
MERRETT.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE MISTER MESSAGE WOULD YOU
LIKE CLASS.
I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU CLERK WILL OPEN THE
WRONG -- MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTEEN AB SIXTEEN OH FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN OH FIVE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER TING AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TRANSPORTATION.
MR TING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER [inaudible]
I THANK YOU MEMBERS OF YOUR
PRESENT AB. SIXTEEN OH FIVE
SIXTEEN FULL OF OUR WITH THE
DISTRICT BILL IT AUTHORIZES THE
SANDERS.
WE'LL GIVE YOU.
TEN IS A DISTRICT BILL IT
AUTHORIZES THE CITY COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO TO CHARGE A FEE TO
IMPLEMENT A RESERVATION SYSTEM
ON ONE OF THE MOST FAMOUS
STREETS IN OUR CITY.
THE STREET OF LUMBAR STREET
WHICH WE CALL THE CRICKET STREET --
LUMBAR STREET AS YOU KNOW IS A
HUGE TOURIST ATTRACTION IT
ATTRACTS UPWARDS OF TWO MILLION
PEOPLE A YEAR.
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF THE
AMOUNT OF INTEREST THAT PEOPLE
WANT HAVE IN DRIVING DOWN LAMAR
STREET OFTENTIMES TRAFFIC WILL
GET BLOCKED OR HELD OR VERY
DIFFICULT TO MOVE AROUND FOR
ABOUT THREE TO FOUR BLOCKS
AROUND LUMBAR STREET.
IN THE SUMMERTIME THEY MAY
ACTUALLY HAVE AS MANY AS TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE A DAY.
SO IF YOU ACTUALLY LIVE IN THE
AREA IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO RUN
ERRANDS.
GET TO WORK DROP YOUR CHILDREN
UP AT SCHOOL GO THE GROCERY
STORE WITHOUT HAVING TO GET BACK
IN LINE. TO GET BACK INTO YOUR
GARAGE SO THIS IS BEEN RESEARCH --
FOR OVER THREE YEARS BY OUR SAN
FRANCISCO TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY -- THIS WASN'T THE
FIRST SOLUTION BUT THIS IS NOW
THE SOLUTION THAT THEY BELIEVE
IS THE BEST WAY THE RESERVATION
SYSTEM WILL ALLOW TO HAVE LEFT
CONGESTION.
WILL ALSO GO TO PAY FOR PEOPLE
WHO WILL HELP MANAGE BOTH THE
VEHICULAR TRAFFIC AND AS WELL AS
THE PEDESTRIANS TO STAND BY WANT
TO WALK THE STREET AS WELL AS
TAKE PICTURES.
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE FOR A. B..
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN OH FIVE SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED OF
A MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALONG MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A
CLEAR.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY SIX
NEWS FIFTEEN THIS MEASURE PASSES
.
WE ARE PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL
AND FILE ITEM ONE OR THREE AB
SEVEN FORTY NINE THE CLERK WILL
POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE --
MEMBERS DIRTY DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR STONE IS THE CALL
MOVING TO
FILE ITEM ONE NINETEEN AB THREE
SEVENTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SEVENTY NINE
FIVE FAMILY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO YOUTH
ATHLETICS.
MR MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER CURRENT
CONCUSSION PROTOCOL REQUIRES A
YOUTH ATHLETE TO BE REMOVED FROM
THE ACTIVITY FOR THE REMAINDER
OF THE DAY.
AND SHALL NOT BE PERMITTED TO
RETURN INTO THE ATHLETE IS ABOUT
EVALUATED BY A HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONAL.
AB THREE SEVENTY NINE WILL
REQUIRE THE SAME PROTOCOLS USED
FOR CONCUSSIONS IN YOUTH AND
HIGH SCHOOL SPORTS TO BE USED IN
SUDDEN CARDIAC ARREST ABOUTS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MAIENSCHEIN.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES
MOVING
TO FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY ONE AB
TWELVE TWENTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE TWENTY ONE
BY SOMETHING NUMBER COOLEY AND
ACTUALLY TO CHILD ABUSE.
MR COOL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
COLLEAGUES AB TWELVE TWENTY ONE
ESTABLISHES STANDARDS FOR CHILD
ADVOCACY CENTERS.
THAT IS A RUBRIC WHICH DOES NOT
HAVE A STATUTORY DEFINITION.
BUT THE BEST CHILD ADVOCACY
CENTERS ARE MULTI DISPONER
CENTERS LAWN FORCE OF MENTAL
HEALTH.
AN ARRAY OF SERVICES TO ENSURE
IN ONE STOP WITH A MINIMUM OF
TERM LOCUSTS THE ASSISTANCE THEY
NEED.
SO WE'RE JUST PRESS OF FIND WHAT
IS COVERED UNDER THIS FOR
PURPOSES OF ESTABLISHING
UNIFORMITY AROUND THE STATED
COUNTY LEVEL ARJUN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE -- MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
TWO A. B. ELEVEN OH SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN OH SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KANSEN CHU AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO WORKERS
COMPENSATION.
SIR TO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THE CENTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKERS AND
MEMBERS I RUSHED THROUGH PERCENT
AB ELEVEN OO SEVEN WHICH SERVE
AS A VEHICLE FOR UNCLE AND
DISCUSSION WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON
WAYS TO ENSURE TIME THE
PROCESSING OF WORKMAN'S
COMPENSATION CLAIMS.
AND GETTING WORKERS BACK TO WORK
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE WELL ONCE
AGAIN THIS BILL IS A VEHICLE FOR
ON GOING DISCUSSION AND I ASK
FOR YOUR ARRIVAL.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
WORK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE EYES FIFTY TWO NO ZERO
THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
AB THREE TWENTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY A. B..
THIRTY TWO THREE TWENTY ONE AS
UNABLE THREE TWENTY ONE BY SOME
REMEMBER PATTERSON AND ACTUALLY
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
MISTER PATTERSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK AMEND SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
THREE TWENTY ONE SEEKS TO BRING
PARITY TO THE LAW REGARDING
TAXATION. FOR COMMERCIAL TRUCKS
AND TRAILERS USED IN INTERSTATE
COMMERCE.
CURRENTLY A COMMERCIAL VEHICLE
PURCHASED IN CALIFORNIA MUST
MAKE ITS INITIAL TRIP WITH A
LOADED INTO THE STATE TO QUALIFY
AS PARTICIPATING IN INTERSTATE
COMMERCE. FOR TAX PURPOSES EVEN
IF IT WAS PURCHASED IN
CALIFORNIA.
MANDATING THIS INBOUND TRIP
REQUIRE AT REQUIRES INCREASED UP
A POLLUTION -- WEAR AND TEAR ON
ROADS AND IT DISCOURAGES BUYERS
FROM PURCHASING THEIR COMMERCIAL
TRUCKS IN CALIFORNIA.
NOW COMPARE THIS WITH PURCHASES
OF COMMERCIAL TRAILERS USED IN
INTERSTATE COMMERCE ONLY NEED TO
LEAVE THE STATE WITHIN SEVENTY
FIVE DAYS WITH THE TRAILER AND
ITS FIRST LOAD.
HAVING TWO DIFFERENT
REQUIREMENTS DOES NOT MAKE SENSE
IT'S ESPECIALLY BURDENSOME WHEN
POTENTIAL BUYERS ARE SEEKING TO
BUY BOTH.
A TRUCK AND THE TRAILER IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THEN HAVE TO MEET
THESE DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS AB.
THREE TWENTY ONE SIMPLY APPLIES
THE SAME STANDARDS TO BOTH
COMMERCIAL TRAILERS IN VEHICLES
PURCHASED IN CALIFORNIA FOR USE
IN INTERSTATE COMMERCE IS BILLS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
HAS NO OPPOSITION I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON AND
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERVE A
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRED
VOTE THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
ONE NO ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
TWO AB THREE SEVENTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ.
THAT'S ONLY WILL THREE SEVENTY
SEVEN BY SOMETHING MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY RETAIL FOOD FACILITIES
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE UP
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MR GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES A.
B. THREE SEVEN SEVEN IS A CLEAN
UP.
BILL TO A. B. SIX TWO SIX WHICH
ESTABLISHED THE MICRO ENTERPRISE
HOME KITCHEN OPERATIONS AS A NEW
TYPE OF RESTRICTED FOOD FACILITY
IN CALIFORNIA -- THIS BILL WAS
VOTED ON LAST SESSION AND
RECEIVED SEVENTY SEVEN VOTES --
IN SUPPORT -- THE CLEAN UP.
OUR AMENDMENTS THAT WERE PUT
FORWARD BY THE COUNTY HEALTH
OFFICERS THE ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH OFFICERS AS WELL AS THE
ASSOCIATION.
OF COUNTY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK REVIVAL.
AND IT DOES HAVE AN EMERGENCY
CLAUSE. FOR THE PURPOSE OF
IMPLEMENTATION -- AS THE ****
PRIOR LAW -- PRESENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR GARCIA S. SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERTED
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED
OF A MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE ON THERE IS NO DESIRE TO
VOTE THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
ON THE URGENCY.
I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES [inaudible]
MOVING.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
THREE EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY FIVE
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR EIGHTY FIVE
BY SEVEN MEMBER MEDINA AND
ACTUALLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
MR MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
AB FOR EIGHTY FIVE SEEKS TO
EXPAND CURRENT LAW. TO INFORM
THE PUBLIC WITH DETAIL
INFORMATION BEFORE LOCAL
DISTRICTS APPROVED TAXPAYER
FUNDED SUBSIDIES FOR WAREHOUSE
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS.
THIS BILL IS AIMED AT HOLDING
COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE TO
PROMISES MADE WHEN THEY WERE
ASKING FOR THE SUBSIDY.
AB FOR EIGHTY FIVE WILL FURTHER
INCREASE PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY BY
MAKING THIS INFORMATION
AVAILABLE VIA GOBIZ RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE.
TO ALONG MEMBERS VOTER DESIRED
OF A OUR MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE -- MEMBERS THIRTY DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE EYES FORTY FIVE NEWS
FIFTEEN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW AND
ACTUALLY THE CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES DECLARING THEIR TO
SEE THEIR UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
MR LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MANISTIQUE REMEMBERS AB
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT ATTEMPTS TO
ADDRESS THE OKAY CRISIS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALENT ABOUT AYE AYES SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO ZERO THE URGENCY?
ON THE URGENCY.
THIS.
I SIX SIX NO ZEROS MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
SIX EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE EIGHTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW MOAN AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC LANDS.
MISS MON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE UPDATES THE ITEM
THAT THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION
MAYES SAYS.
WHEN IT CONSIDERS WHETHER TO
APPROVE AN OFFSHORE OIL GAS AND
LEASE TRANSFER MIR'S FEDERAL
RIGHT REGULATIONS ON THE
COMMISSION RESPONSIBILITY AND
CLARIFIES EXISTING?
POLICE POWERS WHEN THE STATE HAS
TO DECOMMISSION OPERATIONS TO
PROTECT HEALTH AND SAFETY THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILLS TO REDUCE
OR ELIMINATE THE STATE'S FUTURE
FINANCIAL LIABILITY FOR
DECOMMISSIONING OIL AND GAS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND TO ENSURE THAT ALL OPERATORS
TO FILL THE CONTRACTUAL DE
COMMISSIONING OBLIGATIONS IN
THEIR LEASES WE HAVE HEARD FROM
OPPOSITION AND ARE WORKING TO
CLARIFY LANGUAGE AND DEFINITIONS
WITH THE OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS ALONE.
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS OUT OF A
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES.
HIGHS FORTY ONE NO.
SEVENTEEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WILL GO NEXT AND FILE
ORDERED ITEMS [inaudible]
ONE THIRTY WE THE BILL.
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL ON MR STONE'S MEASURE FILE
ITEM.
ONE OH THREE EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY
NINE THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE -- ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE -- BUT MEMBERS
MISTER CALDERON PLACE CALL.
MEMBERS WE WILL MOVE TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT COUNTER.
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO AND
ACTUALLY THE MENTAL HEALTH.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE IN
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR?
WILL THE FURTHER READING OF THE
BILLS AFTER THE ROLL CALL VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE ON THE CONSENT AGENDA.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
EIGHT NO.
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED
.
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL ON MR STONE'S ITEM -- FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE OH THREE
ASSEMBLY BILL.
SEVEN FORTY NINE THE CLERK A
POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
LOCAL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTES AYE AYES FORTY ONE
KNOWS.
EIGHTEEN THE MEASURE
[inaudible]
IT PASSES
.
MEMBERS MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS.
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE.
OUR COLLEAGUE MISTER JIM FRAZIER
WHOSE BIRTHDAY IS THIS SATURDAY.
MEMBERS WOULD YOU PLEASE JOIN ME
IN A KNOWLEDGE IN.
MISTER FRASER AND WISH HIM A
HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
MEMBERS ALSO UNDER ANNOUNCEMENTS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY'S GAS IN
THE FAMILY WILL BE SINGING IN
THE ROTUNDA UPON A GERMAN OF
SESSION.
THIS SESSION SCHEDULED SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY MAY THIRD
NO FLOOR SESSION NO CHECK IN
SESSION MONDAY MAY SIXTH FLOOR
SESSION AT ONE PM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED AND WILL
NOW MOVES TO ME.
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR
.
THERE'S A CALL HAS BEEN LIFTED.
WE'RE MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY AND ASK YOU TO PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
WERE GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MR MAIENSCHEIN YOUR RECOGNIZED
AT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF LAURIE GILBERT
K..
ON SATURDAY LAURIE JOING DOZENS
OF OTHER CONGREGANTS TO ATTEND
SERVICES ON THE LAST DAY OF
PASSOVER.
AT THE HAVE BOUGHT OF POWER WAY
A SPACE THAT IS CONSIDERED SAFE
AND SACRED.
AS WE KNOW.
THEY WERE INTERRUPTED BY AN ACT
OF HATRED AND VIOLENCE.
LAURIE DIED THE WAY SHE LIVED
GIVING OF HERSELF FOR THOSE IN
NEED.
WHEN THE SHOOTING BEGAN LAURIE
SELFLESSLY SACRIFICED HER OWN
LIFE BY STANDING IN FRONT OF
RABBI GOLDSTINE WHO IS BEING
TARGETED BY THE SHOOTER?
HER ACTIONS SAVED HIS LIFE.
LORIS DESCRIBED A THOSE WHO KNEW
HER AS A JEWISH HERO AND A WOMAN
OF VALOR.
SHE WAS DEDICATED TO HER FAMILY
HER FRIENDS AND HER FAITH.
LAURIE BELIEVED IN KINDNESS AND
FORGIVENESS AND THOUGHT OF
OTHERS BEFORE THINKING OF
HERSELF.
AS WE REMEMBER LAURIE I ALSO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE RABBI
GOLDSTINE AMONG PRATT'S AN EIGHT
YEAR OLD NóI A DAY HAN WHO WERE
ALSO INJURED AND THANKFULLY
SURVIVED.
OUR THOUGHTS AND OUR SUPPORTER
WITH THEM DURING THE RECOVERY.
THIS KIND OF WHICH HAVE HATRED
THAT WE WITNESSED.
HAS NO PLACE.
IN OUR SOCIETY.
AND IT'S HAPPENED TOO MANY TIMES
TO COUNT.
OUR DIVERSITY SHOULD BE
CELEBRATED AND WE MUST ANNOUNCE
THOSE WHO SEEK TO DIVIDE US.
AT LAURIE'S FUNERAL ON MONDAY I
WAS STRUCK BY HOW MANY PEOPLE
TALKED ABOUT HER CARING AND
GIVING SPIRIT THAT SHE WAS THE
ONE WHO ALWAYS PROVIDED GIFTS
FOR PEOPLE.
THAT ALWAYS REMEMBEREDBIRTHDAYS
AND HOLIDAYS.
SHE WAS FUNNY SHE WAS CHARMING
AND SHE WAS JUST UNIVERSALLY
LOVED BY EVERYBODY WHO CAME
ACROSS ACROSS HER.
THE FUNERAL WAS WAS REALLY -- AN
INCREDIBLE OCCURRENCE OF NOT
JUST THE CONGREGATION OF HER BOD --
BUT THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY COMING
TOGETHER AT TO STAND UP FOR THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY TO STAND UP FOR
THE COMMUNITY TO SHOW.
THAT THE THAT WE WERE UNITED
AGAINST JUST THE SORT OF
VIOLENCE.
THIS IS THE COMMUNITY THAT I
GREW UP AND I WENT TO HIGH
SCHOOL AND IT'S NOT THE PLACE
THAT SUPPORTS IN ANY WAY.
THIS KIND OF HATRED AND I THINK
WE CAN LIVE UP TO LORI'S LEGACY
BY LIFTING EACH OTHER UP.
IN THE SPIRIT OF PEACE
ACCEPTANCE.
AND SERVICE TO OTHERS MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO HONOR
LAURIE GILBERT KAY'S LIFE AND
HEROISM BY JOURNEYING IN HER
MEMORY MAY HER MEMORY BE A
BLESSING.
THANK YOU MISTER MAIENSCHEIN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FONG YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF MY FRIEND MENTOR AND
ME LEADER.
A CHECK ADDED.
JACK WAS A WELL KNOWN NAME IN
THE CAR DEALERS INDUSTRY IN KERN
COUNTY.
JACK OPENED HIS FIRST DEALERSHIP
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE AND
MOVED TO BAKERSFIELD TO OPEN IT.
I HAD A DODGE DEALERSHIP IN.
NINETEEN THIRTY FOUR ASIDE FROM
BEING A WELL KNOWN BUSINESSMAN
IN HIS FAMILY OPENING MANY
DEALERSHIPS A BAKERSFIELD.
HE WAS AN ACTIVE COMMUNITY
LEADER AND SERVE THE MANY BOARDS
INCLUDING THE CAL STATE BIGGEST
WAS BUSINESS ADVISORY PANEL THE
GREATER BIG SO CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THE KERN COUNTY
HISPANIC CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
WE CAN COUNTY MUSEUM AND THE
PATROLLING CLUB.
HIS DEALERSHIPS ARE GENEROUS
SUPPORTERS OF NONPROFITS AND
CHARITIES THROUGHOUT KERN COUNTY.
CHECK ALWAYS PRIORITIZES FAMILY
YOU COULD NOT HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH JACK WITHOUT
HIM TALKING ABOUT HIS CHILDREN
AND GRANDCHILDREN.
JACK'S WIFE ANGER DIED IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE AND HIS SON
JEFF DIED IN.
TWO TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN HE IS
SURVIVED BY A SON JAMES AND HIS
WIFE LISA SON JOHN HAD ADD AND
SIX GRANDCHILDREN.
CHUCK IS KNOWN FOR HIS FAVORITE
PIECE OF ADVICE KEEP SMILING.
AND WE KNOW HE IS SMILING UPON
US TODAY.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
HONORING THE MEMORY OF CHECK AT
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY NUMBER FONG.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COM LONGER THAT
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
JOHN DANIEL SINGLETON WHO PASSED
AWAY ON APRIL.
TWENTY NINE TWENTY NINETEEN AT
THE YOUNG AGE OF FIFTY ONE JOHN
WAS BORN ON JANUARY SIXTH
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT AND LOS
ANGELES.
HE WAS A TALENTED FILM AND
TELEVISION DIRECTOR SCREENWRITER
AND PRODUCER.
AN ALUMNUS OF MY ALMA MATER USC
AND A RESIDENT OF THE FIFTY
FOURTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
JOHN RECEIVED TWO OSCAR
NOMINATIONS FOR DIRECTING AND
WRITING HIS DEBUT FILM BOYZ IN
THE HOOD.
JUST TWENTY FOUR YEARS OLD HE
WAS THE YOUNGEST FILMMAKER AND
FIRST BLACK DIRECTOR TO RECEIVE
THE BEST DIRECTOR NOMINATION.
THE FILM WAS A COMING OF AGE
TEENAGE TALE THAT TAPPED INTO
UNIVERSAL FEELINGS ABOUT COMING
OF AGE IN THE ENVIRONMENT THAT
SHAPED YOU.
IT HUMANIZES THE HARDSHIPS OF
LIFE IN SOUTH LA AND
DEMONSTRATED THE BEAUTY OF THE
COMMUNITY.
IT WAS A WEST COAST URBAN
VERSION OF THE BREAKFAST CLUB
AND SIXTEEN CANDLES.
IT WAS ALSO THE FIRST IN HIS
HOOD TRILOGY OF BLOCKBUSTER
TEENAGE FILMS.
BOYZ N. THE HOOD POETIC JUSTICE
AND HIGHER LEARNING.
THAT INTRODUCED AUDIENCES TO
FRESH FACES THAT WOULD BECOME
HOUSEHOLD NAMES IN THE FILM
INDUSTRY.
I SHOULD ALSO MENTION AS AN
HONORABLE MENTION THAT BABY BOY
IS IN THAT AS WELL AND I KNOW SO
MANY FOLKS WHO COME UP TO ME
DURING THE COURSE OF THE DAY.
AND WILL GIVE ME A LINE OR A
COUPLE OF LINES FROM THAT MOVIE.
JOHNS ABILITY TO SHOWCASE WHAT
HE SIGNED HIS NEIGHBORHOOD MADE
HIM AN ACTIVIST IN ADDITION TO A
REMARKABLE STORY TELLER.
IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO JOHN USED
HIS INFLUENCE TO TESTIFY BEFORE
THE UNITED STATES SENATE ABOUT
RISING HOMICIDE RATES AMONG
YOUTH.
AT THE COMMITTEE HEARING HE
STATED MY INTENTION IS TO SHED
LIGHT ON SOME THINGS THAT MAY
NOT BE GETTING EMPHASIS WHEN
SPEAKING TO THE VIOLENT
CONDITIONS ARE CHILDREN IN THIS
COUNTRY ARE GOING THROUGH NOW.
THE CONDITION IN WHICH THESE
CHILDREN LIVE DID NOT JUST POP
UP LIKE MAGIC THEY WERE CREATED.
MOST OF THE GUNS THAT CHILDREN
RECEIVE ARE REQUIRED THROUGH
ILLEGAL MEANS AND MAY TRICKLE
AND MANY TRICKLE DOWN FROM
ORGANIZED EFFORTS.
AND IT IS THE FACT THAT THE DRUG
TRADE IN THIS COUNTRY IS LARGELY
AND INTENTIONALLY CONCENTRATED
MOST IN URBAN AREAS.
AND IS NOT IN THE CONTROL OF
THOSE THAT LIVE IN THE CITIES OR
THOSE MOST ADVERSELY AFFECTED.
AFTER BOYS IN THE HOOD JOHN WENT
ON TO DIRECT MORE THAN TEN FILMS
AND TELEVISION SERIES HIS LOVE
AN INVOLVEMENT FOR OUR COMMUNITY
SHOW THROUGH HIS WORK.
JOHNSTONE ROSEWOOD COMPELLED
AUDIENCES TO RECKON WITH OUR
COUNTRY'S COMPLICATED HISTORY IN
REGARD TO RACE.
HIS CHAU SNOW FALL MADE
AUDIENCES AWARE OF THE REALITIES
IN PAIN COMMUNITY MEMBERS FACED
DURING THE CRACK COCAINE
EPIDEMIC.
JOHN MADE SURE THAT OUR
COMMUNITY BENEFITTED FROM HIS
SUCCESS HIS FILMS DEPICTING
SOUTH LA WERE FILMED ON SOUTH LA
STREETS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY PLAY THE MAJOR ROLES.
WHILE FILMING BOYS IN THE HOOD
CROWDS WOULD ASSEMBLE.
AND WATCH AND THEN SHE YEAR
AFTER EACH TAKE.
HIS OFFICES WERE IN CRENSHAW AND
97% OF HIS CREWS WERE AFRICAN
AMERICAN.
JOHN WAS ALSO A LOVING AND
SUPPORTIVE FATHER SON BROTHER.
FRATERNITY BROTHER AND FRIEND.
WHO IN ADDITION TO THE POWER OF
FILM BELIEVED IN HIGHER
EDUCATION BLACK CULTURE AN OLD
SCHOOL MUSIC?
JOHN ALSO LEFT KAYAKING IN
MARINA DEL REY HE LOVES SAILING
HIS BOAT JAY'S DREAM AND ONE OF
HIS FAVORITE SONGS WAS ONE MORE
DAY FROM LAME AS A ROB.
MY SYMPATHY IS WITH HIS PARENTS
HIS SEVEN CHILDREN SIBLINGS
RELATIVES AND FRIENDS.
UPON PASSING HIS FAMILY SHARED
HOW HE STRUGGLED WITH
HYPERTENSION AND ASKED ALL OF US
ESPECIALLY THOSE FROM THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY TO
CHECK OUR PRESSURE.
I ALSO WANT TO ADD THAT I WENT
TO USC.
AND I STARTED RIGHT AFTER HE
GRADUATED AND HE WAS A LEGEND ON
THAT CAMPUS.
HE WAS AN ICON FOR MANY OF THE
FOLKS THAT WERE IN THE FILM
SCHOOL IN THE THEATER SCHOOL HE
WAS AN ICON FOR MANY OF THE
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND HE WAS A
LEGEND TO THE BLACK WE COMMUNITY.
ESPECIALLY THOSE FROM HIS BETA
OMEGA CHAPTER OF KAPPA ALPHA
SIDE.
HE HAD TRULY MADE IT AND HE
SHOWED THAT YOU CAN MAKE IT IN
THE FILM INDUSTRY WITHOUT
NEPOTISM OR CONNECTIONS YOU JUST
NEED A GOOD STORY.
SO I ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME TODAY
IN A JOURNEYING IN THE MEMORY OF
THE LEGENDARY FILMMAKER JOHN
SINGLETON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SOMEONE NEVER COME
LONGER THAT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER YOUR
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY.
WITH A HEAVY HEART TO ADJOURN IN
THE MEMORY.
OF MY FELLOW TROJAN.
A MEMBER OF KAPPA ALPHA SIDE
FRATERNITY MEMBER JOHN SINGLETON.
JOHN WAS A TRUE SON OF LOS
ANGELES GRADUATING FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN NINETEEN NINETY
WITH A DEGREE FROM THE SCHOOL OF
CINEMATIC ARTS HAVING STUDIED
SCREEN WRITING.
IT IS ONLY FITTING.
THAT WE ARE CELEBRATING STAR
WARS DAY TODAY AS JOHN SAID
CITED THE ORIGINAL STAR WARS
FILM AS ONE OF THE STRONGEST
INFLUENCES.
JOHN WAS AN INCREDIBLE TALENT
WRITING WHAT IS PERHAPS HIS MOST
FAMOUS FILM BOYZ IN THE HOOD.
WHILE AT USC AND THEN DIRECTING
IT UPON HIS GRADUATION ANYONE
SAID WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE FIRST
PART OF THE BOYS IN THE HOOD.
YOU KNOW THAT I WASN'T THAT GOOD
OF TO CORRECT A DIRECTOR BUT BY
THE END OF THE OF THE MOVIE YOU
COULD SEE I HAVE PROGRESS
EXTREMELY WELL.
USING KNOWLEDGE FOR HIS GREAT
WORK BY AT THE TENDER AGE OF
TWENTY FOUR YEARS OF AGE HE
BECAME THE YOUNGEST.
AND THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN
TO BE NOMINATED FOR BEST
DIRECTOR AT THE ACADEMY AWARDS.
JOHN USES MOVIES TO TELL STORIES
THAT OFTEN.
DON'T SEE OR OR HEARD.
BOYS IN THE HOOD TELLS THE TALE
OF A YOUNG MAN.
THE YOUNG MAN SENT TO LIVE WITH
HIS FATHER IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES.
SINGLE SINGLE TEN MASSIVELY
PAINTS AN ACCURATE DEPICTION OF
LIFE IN THIS COMMUNITY.
SHOWN IN EFFECTS OF TRAUMA ON
YOUNG MEN.
AND WOMEN.
BUT MOST IMPORTANT WHICH IS
RARELY SEEN IN MOVIES HE SHOWS
HOW STRONG AFRICAN AMERICAN MALE
CAN HAVE A GREAT INFLUENCE ON
ANOTHER AFRICAN AMERICAN MALE IN
A POSITIVE LIGHT.
JOHN ALSO TOLD STORIES REAL
STORIES REFUSING TO DELIVER
AUDIENCES THE SAME REPEATED.
TALES FOR EXAMPLE BOYZ IN THE
HOOD SHOWCASES THE ROLE AS I
SAID EARLIER OF A STRONG BLACK
FATHER IN THE MAIN CHARACTER'S
LIFE.
THROUGH HIS BILL OWNS AND HIS
DEEDS JOHN LEGACY WILL LIVE ON
JOHN ALSO WAS A FELLOW MEMBER.
OF MY FRATERNITY KAPPA ALPHA
C'EST I ALSO WENT OVER A BIT --
MEGAN IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX HE
WENT OVER IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN HE LET THE
FRATERNITIES COMMITMENT TO
COMMUNITY SERVICE.
SOCIAL WELFARE AND MOST
IMPORTANT ACADEMIC SCHOLARSHIP.
HE WAS KNOWN TO REGULARLY MEET
WITH BLACK USC'S DON'T STUDENTS
AND ENCOURAGE THEM ALONG THEIR
EDUCATIONAL JOURNEY.
ALL WITHOUT ANY MEDIA.
OR FANFARE HE DID IT FROM HIS
HEART HE CAME ON CAMPUS TO MEET
WITH STUDENTS TO ENCOURAGE
STUDENTS.
AND HE NEVER WANTED TO GET ANY
CREDIT FOR IT BAND FEAR BECAUSE
THAT'S THE TYPE OF INDIVIDUAL HE
WAS.
FORCED INCREDIBLE EFFORTS TO
BENEFIT OTHERS AND FOR HIS
GROUNDBREAKING CINEMATIC WORK.
JOHN SINGLETON WAS HONORED AS
OUTSTANDING ALUM BY THE U. S. C.
BLACK ALUMNI ASSOCIATION AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND A WART.
I WAS ALSO HAPPY TO RECEIVE AS
WELL THAT YEAR.
JOHN ONCE SAID YOU CAN ONLY
WRITE ABOUT WHAT YOU KNOW ABOUT.
HE FURTHER DESCRIBED IS HIMSELF
SAYING AT HEART.
I'M A DUDE FROM SOUTH LOS
ANGELES.
HIS TALENT ENVISIONED ENABLE THE
WORLD TO SEE AND HEAR ALL SOUTH
LOS ANGELES STORIES.
JOHN DEFINITELY WILL BE SORELY
MISSED BUT LEAVE BEHIND A LEGACY
OF ENCOURAGEMENT AND MOTIVATION.
BREAKING BARRIERS FOR PEOPLE OF
COLOR THROUGHOUT HOLLYWOOD.
I ASKED THAT WE DURING THE
MEMORY OF MY CAP A BROTHER.
JOHN SINGLETON.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER
MISTER FONG RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
SECOND INTERMITTENTLY.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I RISE TODAY TO ASK THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF FRED
STAR.
FRED WAS AN AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY I CON A DYNAMIC FIGURE
IN THE COTTON INDUSTRY AND KEPT
THE FAMILY BUSINESS THRIVING
WITH ALFALFA ALMONDS IS AND
DISPATCHES.
HE WAS ALSO A VISIONARY WHEN I
CAME TO OUR STATE AND COUNTIES
WATER POLICY ADVOCATING FOR
NEEDED WATER BANKING FACILITIES
WHEN NOT NO ONE ELSE THOUGHT IT
WAS POSSIBLE.
FRED WAS A DEDICATED MEMBER OF
THE COMMUNITY HE SERVED AS A
TRUSTEE FOR THE KERN HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
DIRECTOR OF THE KERN COUNTY
WATER AGENCY DIRECTOR OF THE
KERN COUNTY FARM BUREAU WAS ONE
THE FOUNDING MEMBERS OF THE KERN
COUNTY YOUNG FARMERS RANCHERS.
AN ACTIVE ON NUMEROUS NATIONAL
BOARDS AND JIMMY AND COMMITTEES
H WAS ALSO A PASSIONATE
SUPPORTER OF OUR ARTS.
FRED WAS A DEDICATED FAMILY MAN
KERN COUNTY HAS LOST A PILLAR IN
OUR COMMUNITY AND HE WILL BE
MISSED BY SO MANY.
WHO WAS DIRECTLY AND INDIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY HIS LEGACY?
FRED IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
LINDA IS AND FRED SIR JUNIOR AND
HIS WIFE KRIS.
SON LARRY START AS I'VE SHAUNA
DAUGHTER CAROL KROGER YOUR
HUSBAND JAY AND DAUGHTER AND
ACTUALLY INNER HUSBAND DALE AND
NUMEROUS GRANDCHILDREN AND GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN.
FRED WAS A DEAR FRIEND AND MADE
ME IN ANYONE HE MET PART OF HIS
FAMILY.
MY LIFE WAS MADE BETTER BECAUSE
A FRIEND START.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
HONORING THE MEMORY OF RED STARS
SENIOR.
THANK YOU MISTER FONG.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BARRICADE AND
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
JUDGMENT MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF CONGRESSWOMAN ELLEN
TAUSCHER.
CONGRESSWOMAN TAUSCHER WAS ONE
OF THE WOMEN WHO WORK TO BREAK
THE GLASS CEILING SHE WAS A
FIERCE ADVOCATE IN A FIERCE
PUBLIC SERVANT.
CONGRESSWOMAN TAUSCHER WAS THE
FIRST IN HER FAMILY TO ATTEND
COLLEGE IT WAS ONE OF THE FIRST
WOMEN TO EARN A SEAT AT THE NEW
YORK STOCK EXCHANGE.
SHE WAS AN INSPIRATION TO MANY
AND BLAZE THE TRAIL TO LIFT WITH
WOMEN UP WHO CHOSE TO RUN FOR
OFFICE LIKE ME.
ALLEN CHAIR THE HOUSE ARMED
SERVICES COMMITTEE WITH TAPPED
BY THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AS
UNDERSECRETARY OF STATE FOR ARMS
CONTROL AND INTERNATIONAL
SECURITY.
DURING HER WORK IN THE STATE
DEPARTMENT CONGRESSWOMAN
TAUSCHER WORKED TIRELESSLY TO
CREATE A SAFER WORLD FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS.
BY BEING AN INTERVAL ARCHITECT
IN NEGOTIATING THE REDUCTION OF
ARMS WITH RUSSIA.
AFTER CONCLUDING HER WORK WITH
THE STATE DEPARTMENT HER SERVICE
DID NOT END THERE.
CONGRESSWOMAN TAUSCHER WENT ON
TO BECOME THE CHAIR OF THE BOARD
OF THE NATIONAL COMPREHENSIVE
CANCER NETWORK FOUNDATION.
IT WAS ON THE BOARD OF REGENTS
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND SPENT THE LAST YEARS OF HER
LIFE DEFENDING OUR DEMOCRACY.
CONGRESSWOMAN TAUSCHER WAS
DESCRIBED BY HER COLLEAGUES IS
BRILLIANT.
GRACIOUS AND ALWAYS DID HER BEST
TO LIVE UP THOSE AROUND HER.
SHE WAS A CHAMPION FOR OUR GREAT
STATE AND A MENTOR TO FUTURE
LEADERS OF THIS COUNTRY.
SHE ALWAYS PUT OUR COMMUNITY
AHEAD OF THE SPECIAL INTERESTS.
NGOR SOMEONE TOUCHES LEGACY WILL
LIVE ON IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE NATION.
MY DEEPEST SYMPATHIES TO HER
FAMILY.
AND LOVED ONES DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME.
MAY HER MEMORY BE A BLESSING.
THANK YOU -- MR GRAYSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO
TODAY RISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
OF ELLEN TAUSCHER.
AS A CONGRESSWOMAN A STATE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
AND A UC REGENT ALLEN'S
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVICE AND
RICH THE LIVES OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS IN THE EAST BAY
CALIFORNIA.
AND BEYOND ONLY A FEW MONTHS AGO
I RAN INTO CONGRESSWOMAN
TAUSCHER AT AN EVENT FOR THE UC.
I WAS THRILLED TO HAVE ONE OF MY
FEMALE LEGISLATIVE ASSISTANCE
COME ALONG.
THAT WAY SHE COULD MEET THE
WOMAN WHO HAD BROKEN BARRIERS
BLAZE TRAILS THAT INSPIRED HER
OWN SUCCESS AND POLITICS.
ALLEN WAS A ROLE MODEL TO ALL
INCLUDING ME BUT HER IMPACT ON
YOUNG WOMEN STILL AND WILL
REMAIN ESPECIALLY MEANINGFUL.
AS HER FAMILY HAS SAID IN HER
PASSING SHE SIX SHE SUCCEEDED AT
EVERYTHING SHE DID AND MADE HER
MARK WHEREVER SHE WENT.
ALLEN CERTAINLY LEFT A MARK ON
CONTRA COSTA AND SOLANO COUNTIES
AND SHE WILL BE VERY MUCH AND
DEEPLY MISSED.
I WISH HER FAMILY AND LOVED ONES
COMFORT DURING THIS PAINFUL TIME.
AND ASK THAT MY COLLEAGUES JOIN
ME IN A JOINING AND
CONGRESSWOMAN TAUSCHER IS MEMORY.
THANK YOU SIR SOME IN EVER WAKES
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I TO RISE WITH SADNESS TODAY AS
WE MOURN THE TREMENDOUS LOSS OF
FORMER CONGRESSWOMAN ELLEN
TAUSCHER.
DURING THE TWELVE YEARS SHE
SERVED IN THE US CONGRESS ELLEN
PLAYED AN INVALUABLE ROLE
BRINGING OPPOSING FACTIONS
TOGETHER WITH HER LEADERSHIP.
NEGOTIATION SKILLS AND
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH TO TO VISIT
ISSUES.
SHE WAS A FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR
WOMEN'S RIGHTS RIGHTS FOR OUR
LGBTQ COMMUNITY COMMON SENSE GUN
SAFETY LEGISLATION AFFORDABLE
CHILDCARE.
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND A
HOST OF MANY OTHER IMPORTANT
ISSUES.
AS UNDERSECRETARY OF STATE FOR
ARMS CONTROL FOR PRESIDENT OBAMA
SHE PLAYED A KEY ROLE IN
NEGOTIATING MAJOR INTERNATIONAL
NUCLEAR ARMS TREES MAKING OUR
COUNTRY AND WORLD A MUCH SAFER
PLACE.
UNDER EXCEPTIONAL POLITICAL
CAREER DEDICATION TO OUR STATE
AND OUR COUNTRY.
ELLEN WAS A MENTOR TO COUNTLESS
YOUNG PEOPLE NTERESTED IN
PUBLIC SERVICE PARTICULARLY
WOMEN ENTERING POLITICS.
I WAS VERY LUCKY TO CALL HER A
FRIEND AND A MENTOR AND A
SUPPORTER IN MY EFFORT TO GET
INTO THIS BODY.
ELLEN WAS NOT ONLY A TRAILBLAZER
FOR WOMEN SHE MADE CERTAIN THAT
THOSE WHO FOLLOWED IN HER
FOOTSTEPS HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SUPPORT AND SUCCEED.
MY CONDOLENCES TO HER FRIENDS
AND FAMILY SHE WILL BE MISSED
TERRIBLY.
AND I ASK THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
ADJOURNED HER MEMORY TODAY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
OF TO THE DESK TO BE PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL.
ALL REQUESTS TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AT SOME LEVEL.
FIFTEEN FIFTY THREE I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO LEGAL EIGHTEEN
FOURTEEN I SIXTY EIGHT NEW ZERO
SOME LEVEL EIGHT FOURTEEN I
SIXTY EIGHT ZERO CYCLE THIRTY
FOUR I SIXTY NO. ZERO TWO SEVEN
AYE SIXTY EIGHT ZERO ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO FORTY I SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO SOMETHING ABOUT TWO SIXTY
SEVEN AYE SIXTY EIGHT ZERO ONLY
FOURTEEN NINETY THREE I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE THREE
OH FIVE HI SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO
IT'S ONLY ABOUT.
THREE SIXTY ONE I SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO SOMETHING ABOUT THREE
NINETY EIGHT I SIXTY EIGHT A
ZERO SUM Là FOR FORTY SEVEN AYE
SIXTY EIGHT ZERO SUM Là FOR
FIFTY THREE I SIXTY EIGHT ZERO
SOMETHING BEFORE FIFTY EIGHT I
SIXTY EIGHT ZERO SOME PEOPLE FOR
EIGHTY SEVEN AYE SIXTY EIGHT NO.
ZERO SOMETHING BEFORE EIGHTY
EIGHT I SIXTY EIGHT ZERO SOME
REAL FOR NINETY EIGHT I SIXTY
EIGHT ZERO FIVE OH FOUR I SIXTY
EIGHT A ZERO SUM LEGAL FIVE
FORTY THREE HI. SIXTY EIGHT ZERO
FIVE FORTY EIGHT I SIXTY EIGHT
ZERO SOMEONE WILL FIVE SIXTY SIX
I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO CYNICAL
SIX OH EIGHT I SIXTY EIGHT ZERO
SOME PEOPLE SIX FORTY NINE I
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO LEVEL SIX
EIGHTY SIX I. SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO SUM OF ALL.
SEVEN OH NINE I SIXTY EIGHT ZERO
WASN'T ABLE SEVEN TEN I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SOME REAL SEVEN
FOURTEEN WITH URGENCY I SIXTY
EIGHT ZERO ON THE URGENCY.
I SIXTY EIGHT ZERO ON THE BILL
AS I HAVE A SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
AYE SIXTY EIGHT A ZERO SUM WILL
SEVEN THIRTY SIX I SIXTY EIGHT
ZERO SOME PEOPLE SEVEN FORTY
SEVEN AYE SIXTY EIGHT ZERO SOME
OF THE SEVEN FIFTY FOUR I SIXTY
EIGHT ZERO SOME PEOPLE.
SEVEN SIXTY ONE I SIXTY EIGHT
ZERO LEVEL SEVENTY FIVE I SIXTY
EIGHT ZERO CYCLE EIGHT SIXTY AYE
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
EIGHT SIXTY FOUR I SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO UNABLE IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO HI. SIXTY EIGHT ZERO
ONE NINE EIGHTY EIGHT I SIXTY
EIGHT ZERO SOMETHING WILL NINE
NINETY THREE I SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO SOME LEVEL ONE THOUSAND I
SIXTY EIGHT ZERO SOMETHING WELL
TEN THIRTY SEVEN AYE SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO SEVERAL TEN FORTY FOUR I
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO SUM OF ALL.
TIME EIGHTY FOUR I SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO FIVE ELEVEN TWENTY NINE
I SIXTY EIGHT A ZERO SUM OF ALL
FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE ISAAC CA NO
ZERO SAN ALSO ELEVEN TWENTY NINE
I SIXTY EIGHT ZERO SOMETHING
VOCAL THIRTEEN I SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO SOME PEOPLE.
TWELVE THIRTY FIVE I SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE CALL THIRTY
SEVEN AYE SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS THE
LABEL TWELVE FORTY I SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO SIMILAR TWELVE NINETY
FOUR I SIXTY EIGHT ZERO CYNICAL
THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN AYE SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
THIRTEEN SEVENTY TWO I SIXTY
EIGHT NO. ZERO SOME PEOPLE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR I SIXTY
EIGHT ZERO A SINGLE THIRTY
NINETY TWO I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO
SOME PEOPLE FOURTEEN FOURTEEN I
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO SOME LEVEL
FOURTEEN SEVENTY THREE I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SUM IT WILL
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE I SIXTY
EIGHT NO.
ZERO SOME OF THE FIFTEEN
FOURTEEN WITH URGENCY I SIX A NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY IN AYE SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE BILL AT
SOME LEVEL SIXTEEN FIFTY ONE I
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO AS I WILL
SEVENTY TWENTY I SIXTY EIGHT NO.
ZERO SUM ABLE SEVENTEEN NINETY
FOUR I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO SOME
PEOPLE EIGHTEEN HUNDRED I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
EIGHTEEN OH FOUR I SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN AYE SIXTY EIGHT
KNOWS HE WASN'T ABLE TO SEVEN
FIFTY NINE I SIXTY EIGHT NO.
ZERO A SUMMIT WILL TWELVE SIXTY
FIVE WITH URGENCY I SIXTY NO
ZERO URGENCY AYE SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO ON THE BILL A SOMEWHAT
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SIX I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SUM IT LOOKS COOL
TWENTY I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO
SOME LEVEL FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR I
SIXTY EIGHT ZERO AND IT'S ON THE
BILL. FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN I
SIXTY EIGHT NO.
ZERO THAT COMPLETES THE CONSENT
AGENDA YOU'RE WELCOME.
I WILL WILL -- VERY GOOD ALL
OTHER ITEMS FOR A REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CAN TO UNTIL MONDAY MAY
SIXTH AT ONE PM.
WE ARE JR
.
BAUER-KAHAN AB SIXTEEN OH FIVE
CHANGE FROM A NOTE TO A NOT
VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BY
BAUER-KAHAN ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN OH FIVE NO TO NOT VOTING.
GOOD MORNING IT IS MY HONOR TO
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
CAPITOL AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY.
A VERY INCREDIBLE GROUP OF THE
EYE PEAS VISITING US FROM
ALAMEDA MISTER DONNA ELDERTS.
FOURTH GRADE CLASS -- FROM OTIS
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AND AMONG THIS
INCREDIBLE GROUP OF THE EYE PEAS
ARE TO WHO ARE VERY SPECIAL TO
ME.
MY TEN YEAR OLD SON ANDREAS
BONTA.
AND MY WIFE MIA BONTA.
WELCOME.
OTIS ELEMENTARY STUDENTS.
AND WE'LL DO A SECOND A GERMAN
IN YOUR HONOR.
WE ARE ADJOURNED.
IN HONOR OF MR DONE ELDERS
FOURTH GRADE CLASS [inaudible]
COME ON